so two months ago something crazy
happened can you talk us through this
because this caught so many people's
attention I'll stay quiet for the very
beginning and then I'll start talking
[Applause]
though this is such an important moment
for SpaceX with the Falcon 9 and now the
Falcon Heavy we can launch into orbit
any payload that has previously been
conceived or is conceived right now
we've got a couple of launches of Falcon
Heavy later this year so this had to go
right it was the first time we flew it
and the star of the show of course
brother and sister side boosters landing
I was excited
they'd be like tea by the way this may
be a thousand people standing around me
right there
it's dar man star man did not steal the
show though the Boosters did there had
to be some payload why not put a Tesla
into space
I mean exactly it's perfect Quinn let's
let's wind the talk back I mean how did
you end up an engineer and president of
SpaceX we used super nerdy as a girl I
don't think I was nerdy but I was
definitely doing the things that the
girls weren't doing I asked my mom who
was an artist when I was in third grade
how a car worked so she had no idea so
she gave me a book and I read it and
sure enough my first job out of my
mechanical engineering degree was with
Chrysler Motors in the automotive
industry but I actually got into
engineering not because of that book but
because my mom took me to a Society of
Women Engineers event and I fell in love
with the mechanical engineer that spoke
she was doing really critical work and I
loved her suit and that's that's what a
15 year old girl connects with and I
used to shy away from telling that story
but if that's what caused me to be an
engineer hey I think we should talk
about that
16 years ago you became employee number
seven at SpaceX and then over the next
year's you somehow you you know built a
multibillion-dollar relationship with
NASA despite the fact that SpaceX's
first three launches blew up
I mean how on earth did you do that so
actually selling rockets is all about
relationships and making a connection
with these customers when you don't have
a rocket to sell what's really important
is selling your team selling the
business savvy of your CEO that's not
really hard to sell these days and
basically making sure that any
technical issue that they have or any
concern you couldn't dress right away
so I think was helpful for me to be an
engineer I think was helpful to my role
is running sales for Elan currently a
big focus of the company is I guess kind
of a race with Boeing to be the first to
provide the service to NASA of actually
putting humans into orbit the safety
considerations obviously come to the
fore here how are you sleeping I
actually sleep really well I'm a good
sleeper that's my best thing but I think
the the days leading up to our flying
crew will probably be a little sleepless
but really fundamentally safety comes in
the design of the system that you're
going to fly people on and so we've been
working for years actually almost a
decade on this technology we're taking
the dragon cargo space ship and we're
upgrading it to be able to carry crew
and as I said we've been engineering in
these safety systems for for quite some
time so this isn't there's one system
that actually allows instant escape if
there's a problem that's right it's
called the launch escape system I think
we have that let's show that a video of
a test that we ran in 2015 so this
simulated having a really bad day on the
pad basically you want the capsule to
get out of Dodge you wanted to get away
from the rocket that had a bad day right
below it this is if there was an issue
on the pad we also will be doing another
demonstration later this year on if we
have an issue with the rocket during
flight and those Rockets have another
potential function as well eventually
yeah so the launch escape system for
Dragon is pretty unique it's an
integrated launch escape system it's
basically a pusher so the the propellant
system and the thrusters are integrated
into the capsule and so if it detects a
rocket problem it pushes the capsule
away capsule safety systems in the past
have been like tractor pullers and the
reason we didn't want to do that is that
polar needs to come off before you can
safely reenter that capsule so we wanted
to get eliminate in design that
possibility of failure
I mean SpaceX has made the regular
reusability of rock
seemed almost routine which means you've
done something that no National Space
Program for example has been able to
achieve how was that possible
there's a couple of things that have
allowed well there's a number a million
things actually that have made allowed
SpaceX to be successful the first is
that we're kind of standing on the
shoulders of giants right we got to look
at the rocket industry and the
developments to date and we got to pick
the best ideas leverage them we also
didn't have technology that we had to
include in our vehicle systems so we
didn't have to kind of design around
legacy components that maybe weren't the
most reliable or were particularly
expensive so we really were able to let
physics drive the design of these
systems I mean the other programs
started from scratch that last phrase
you said that you let physics drive the
design what's an example of that
there's hundreds of examples actually of
that but basically we we got to
construct the vehicle design from really
a clean sheet of paper and we got to
make decisions that we wanted to make
the tank architecture it's a common dome
design basically it's like two beer cans
stacked together one full of liquid
oxygen one full of RP and that basically
saved weight allowed us to basically
take more payload for the same design
one of the other elements of the vehicle
that we're flying right now is we do use
densified liquid oxygen and densified RP
so it's ultra cold and it you basically
it packs it allows you to pack more
propellant into the vehicle but it is
done elsewhere probably not to the
degree that we do it but it adds a lot
of margin to the vehicle which obviously
adds reliability Gwyn you became
president of SpaceX ten years ago I
think what's it been like to work so
closely with in our musk so I love
working for Elon
I've been doing it for 16 years this
year actually I I don't think I'm dumb
enough to do something for 16 years that
I do but I don't like doing he's funny
and fundamentally without him saying
anything he drives you to do
your best work he doesn't have to say a
word you just want to do great work you
might be the person best place to answer
this question which has puzzled me which
is to shed light on this strange unit of
time called Elan time for example last
year I are still on you know
when Tesla would also drive across
America and he said by last December
which is definitely true if you take
Elon time into account so how what's the
conversion ratio between Elon time and
real time you put me in a unique
position Chris thanks for that there's
no question that Elon is very aggressive
on his timelines but frankly that drives
us to do things better and faster I
think all the time and all the money in
the world does not yield the best
solution and so putting that pressure on
the team to move quickly is really
important it feels like you play a kind
of a key intermediary role yeah well I
mean he sets these crazy goals that have
to have their impact but but might I
don't know in other circumstances might
blow up a team or set impossible
expectations it feels like you've found
a way of saying yes Elon and then making
it happen in a way that is acceptable
both to him and to your company to your
employees there is two really important
realizations for that first of all when
Elon says something you have to pause
and not immediately say out blurt out
well that's impossible
or there's no way we're gonna do that I
don't know how to do that so you zip it
and you think about it and you find ways
to get that done and the other thing I
realized and it made my job satisfaction
substantially harder so I always felt
like my job was to take these ideas and
kind of turn them into company goals
make them achievable and kind of roll
the company over from this steep slope
get it comfortable and I noticed every
time I felt like we were there we were
rolling over people were getting
comfortable
Elon would throw something out there and
all of a sudden were not comfortable in
work we're climbing that steep slope
again but then once I realized that
that's his job and my job is
to get the comfortably close to
comfortable so he can push again and put
us back on that slope then I started
like my job a lot more frustrated and so
so if I if I estimated that the
conversion ratio for a long time to real
time is about 2x am I am I a long way
out there or terrible and you said it I
didn't you know looking ahead one huge
initiative SpaceX is believed to be
rumored to be working on is a massive
network of saud literally thousands of
low-earth orbit satellites to provide
high bandwidth low-cost internet
connection to every square foot of
planet Earth is there anything you can
tell us about this we actually don't
chat very much about this particular
project not because we're hiding
anything but this is probably one of the
most challenging if not the most
challenging project we've undertaken no
one has been successful deploying a huge
constellation for internet broadband or
basically for satellite internet and I
don't think physics is the difficulty
here I think we can come up with the
right technology solution but we need to
make a business out of it and it'll cost
the company about 10 billion dollars or
more to deploy this system and so we're
marching steadily along but we're
certainly not claiming victory yet I
mean the impact obviously if that
happened to the world of connectivity
everywhere would be pretty radical and
perhaps mainly for good people would
here I mean it changes a lot if suddenly
everyone can connect cheaply yeah
there's no question it'll change the
world is how much of a worry is it and
how much of a drag on the planning is it
a concerns just about space junk people
worry a lot about this this would be a
huge increase in the total number of
satellites in orbit is that a concern so
space debris is a concern there's no
question not because it's it's so likely
to happen but the consequences of it
happening are pretty devastating you
could basically spew a bunch of
particles in orbit that could take out
that orbit from being useful for decades
or longer so as a matter of fact we are
required to bring down our second stage
after every
so it doesn't end up being a rocket
carcass orbiting earth so we do you
really need to be a good steward of that
so despite the remarkable success there
of that Falcon Heavy rocket you're
actually not focusing on that as your
future developed plan you're doubling
down to a much bigger rocket called the
BF R which stands for it's the big
Falcon rocket the big Falcon rocket
that's that's right what what what's the
business logic of doing this when you
you know you invested all that in that
incredible technology and now you're
just going to something much bigger why
actually we've learned some lessons over
over the duration where we've been
developing these launch systems what we
want to do is not introduce a new
product before we've been able to
convince the customers that this is the
product that they should move to so
we're working on the big Falcon rocket
now but we're going to continue flying
Falcon nines and south--and heavies
until there is absolute widespread
acceptance of bfr but we are working on
it right now we're just not going to
cancel Falcon 9 and Falcon Heavy and
just put in place VFR but ok no I mean
the logic is that VFR is what you need
to take humanity to Mars that's correct
but but somehow you've also found other
business ideas for this yes VFR can take
the satellites that we're currently
taking to orbit - at many orbits it
allows for even a new class of
satellites to be delivered to orbit the
basically the the width the diameter of
the fairing is 8 meters so you can think
about what giant telescopes you can put
in that in that fairing in that cargo
bay and see really incredible things and
discover incredible things in space but
then there are some residual
capabilities that we have out of bfr as
well a residual capabilities digital
capability people this talk about what
what the heck this is Oh what is that
heavy but that's worth pointing out by
the way what a beautiful rocket and that
hanger could just fit the Statue of
Liberty in it so you get a sense of size
of that Falcon heavy rocket and the fact
of the
27 engines are that's part of the design
principle that you rather than just
inventing other bigger
rockets you teamed them up it's exactly
this residual capability so we developed
the Merlin engine for the Falcon 1
launch vehicle we could have tossed that
engine and built an entirely new engine
for the Falcon 9 it would have been
called something different obviously
because Falcon 9 is 9 Merlin engines but
instead of spending a billion dollars on
a brand new engine
we put nine of them together on the back
end of Falcon 9 residual capability glue
3 Falcon nines together and you have the
largest operational rocket flying and so
it was expensive to do but it was a much
more efficient path than starting from
scratch and the bfr is the equivalent of
how much bigger than that in terms of
VFR is about two I believe two and a
half times the size of this right and so
that that allows you to I mean I I still
don't really believe this video that
we're about to play head what on earth
is this so it currently is on earth but
this is this is basically space travel
for earthlings
I can't wait for this residual
capability basically what it we're going
to do is we're going to fly bfr like an
aircraft and do point-to-point travel on
earth so you can take off from New York
City or Vancouver and fly halfway across
the globe in a you'll be on the VFR for
a roughly half an hour or 40 minutes and
the longest part of that yeah it's so
awesome the longest part of that flight
is actually the boat out and back I mean
when come on this this this is awesome
but it's crazy right like this is never
going to actually happen oh no it's
definitely gonna happen this is
definitely gonna happen how like
so first of all countries are going to
accept this incoming missile that's
landing on it you know of it so Chris so
can you imagine us trying to convince a
federal range Air Force bases to take
the in comers because we're doing it now
regularly right we're bringing the first
stages back and we're landing them on
federal property on an Air Force Base so
I think doing it I don't know 10
kilometers out from a city maybe it's
only 5 kilometers out from a city how
many passages can possibly afford the
fortune of flying by space so the the
first ship the first VFR is going to
have roughly a hundred passengers and
let's talk a little bit about the
business everyone thinks Rockets are
really expensive and to a large degree
they are and how could we possibly
compete with airline tickets here but if
you think about it if I can do this trip
in half an hour to an hour I can do
dozens of these a day right and yet a
long-haul aircraft can only make one of
those flights a day so even if my rocket
was slightly more expensive and the fuel
is a little bit more expensive
I can run 10x at least what they're
running in a day and really make the
revenue that I need to out of that
system so you really believe this is
going to be deployed at some point in
our amazing future when when do you
within a decade for sure this is one
time or a long time
that's Quint I'm I'm sure you'll all
wanted to go faster that's okay that's
certainly amazing I'm invested in this
one because I travel a lot and I do not
love to travel and I would love to get
to see my customers in Riyadh leave in
the morning and be back in time to make
dinner so we're gonna test so within ten
years
an economy price ticket or like a like a
couple thousand dollars yes a person to
fly New York to Shanghai yeah I think
between economy and business but you do
it in an hour yeah well okay that is
that is definitely something and
meanwhile the other use of VFR is being
developed to go a little bit further
than Shanghai talk about this this is
you guys have actually developed quite a
detailed sort of picture of how humans
might fly to Mars and what
would look like yes so we've got a video
this is a cropped video from others
we've shown and then there's a couple of
new bits to it but basically you're
gonna lift off from a pad you've got a
booster as well as the BFS the big
Falcon spaceship I'm gonna take off the
booster is going to drop the spaceship
off in orbit low-earth orbit and then
return just like we're returning
boosters right now so it sounds
incredible but we're working on the
pieces and you can see us achieve these
pieces so booster comes back the new
thing here is that we're gonna actually
land on the pad that we launched from
currently we land on a separate pad or
we land out on a boat fast Quick Connect
you take a cargo ship full of fuel or a
fuel depot put it on that booster get
that in orbit do a docking maneuver
refuel the spaceship and head on to your
destination and this one is Mars so like
a hundred people go to Mars at one time
taking what to six months two months
it ends up depending on how big the
rocket is I think that's this first
version and will continue to make even
bigger BFRs
I think it's a three month trip right
now the average is like six to eight but
we're gonna try to do it faster when do
you believe SpaceX will learn the first
human on Mars very very similar
timeframe from the point point it's the
same capability it will be within this
decade
within a decade not this decade in real
time again within a decade
well that would also be amazing why
though seriously why I mean you've got
you've got a company where this is the
official stated mission is everyone
actually bought into that mission given
that I mean there's a lot of people here
a lot of people around you think come on
you've got so much talent so much
technology capability there's so many
things on earth that need urgent
attention why why would you have this
escape trip off to another planet so I
am glad you asked that but I think we
need to expand our minds a little bit
there are plenty of things to do on
earth but there are lots of companies
working on that I think we're working
one of the most important things we
possibly can and that's to find another
place for humans to live and survive and
thrive if there were to have something
if something happened on earth you need
humans living somewhere else it's it's
them it's it's the fundamental risk
reduction for the human species and this
does not subvert making our making our
planet here better and doing a better
job taking care of it but I think you
need multiple paths to survival and this
this is one of them and then let's not
talk about the downer piece like you go
to Mars to make sure you know all
Earthlings don't die that's terrible
actually that's a terrible reason to go
do it fundamentally it's another place
to explore and that's what makes humans
different from animals is our sense of
exploration and sense of wonderment and
learning something new and then I also
have to say this is the first step in us
moving to other solar systems and
potentially other galaxies and I think
this is the only time I ever out vision
Elon because I want to meet other people
in other solar systems Mars is fine but
it is a fixer-upper planet there's work
to do there to make it habitable I want
to find people or whatever they call
themselves in another solar system that
is a big vision wind shot well thank you
you have one of the most amazing jobs in
the pack